وانتم الان من دنياتك مراسلتها سلام خضر
ومن خيرسون مراسلنا تامر الصمادي اذا سلام
وتامر اهلا بكما وابدا معك تامر حدثنا عما
يجري في خرصه
بالفعل صباح الخير اولا نصف لا يهدا لا
يتوقف هنا في خير سونا نستطيع القول شكرا
استطيع القول بان القصف هو الاعنف منذ
ايام تحديدا القصف المتبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه على طول جبهات القتال
في خير سواء تحديدا على نهر هذا قصف مدفعي
كثير لا تمر خمس دقائق 10 دقائق الا
ويتجدد القصف المتبادل بين الطرفين طيله
الليله الماضيه لم يتوقف القصف صباح هذا
اليوم بشكل متواصل ايضا السلطات ايضا
تتحدث الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن نوع اخر من
القصف وهو اا قصف المدينه وقلب المدينه
وبالفعل هنالك يعني اكثر من موقع اكثر من
مكان تعرض للقصف داخل المدينه خلال
الساعات الماضيه والعديد من قرى وبلدات
خطوط التماس في خير تتعرض هي الاخرى للقصف
الحديث عن اكثر من 30 هجوم خلال الساعات
الماضيه وفقا للقوات الاوكرانيه من طرف
القوات الروسيه الحديث عن اكثر من 21 قريه
وبلده خلال الساعات الماضيه ايضا تعرضت
للقصف وهو ما دفع السلطات مره اخرى
لمطالبه السكان ومناشادتهم بضروره اخلاء
المدينه بضروره اخلاء الخضراء والبلدات في
الحقيقه هذا الشارع من خلفي كما تشاهدين
ليلى همم يعكس حال المدينه المدينه همم
يعني شبه ميته والحركه شبه متوقفه والناس
يغادرون تباعا الى مقاطعه وسط وغرب
اوكرانيا الاقل تضررا من الحرب لكن ايضا
التطورات في مقاطعه اخرى الحديث عن
ميكولايت المناطق الساحليه تتعرض لقصف
متواصل من قبل هذه اشاهد في هذه الاثناء
ايضا همم مدرعات اوكرانيه تسير في الشارع
همم المحادثي همم السلطات الاوكرانيه قالت
بان القصف الروسي بالفعل تجدد اليوم صباحا
اداء اليوم على ميكولاتات تحديدا المناطق
الساحليه منطقه اشتاقه في هذه المنطقه
المهمه التي تغذي المقاطعه بالمياه الحديث
عن اكثر من 80 قذيفه مدفعيه سقطت خلال
الساعات الماضيه ايضا على همم ميليتوبيل
على ميليتوبيل من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
في زبروديا وتقول القوات بانها كبدت
الجانب الروسي خسائر فادحه في العتاد
والارواح الحديث عن همم يعني ضرب قواعد
خاصه تتمركز فيها القوات الروسيه والحديث
ايضا عن قصف متواصل في منطقه تتعرض له
منطقه في جنوب وسط جنوبيه البلاد من قبل
القوات الروسيه نعم
هذا الامر من جانب القوات الاوكرانيه الذي
تقوله حول همم القصف الروسي في جانب اخر
القوات المواليه لروسيا دونيا تتحدث عن
همم قصف الاوكرانيا مستمر ماذا تقول همم
همم القوات المواليه لروسيا سلام خضر من
دنيتك حدثينا عن الموقف هناك
[موسيقى]
حسن نبدا بالواقع الميداني جبهه افديتك
الواقعه شمال مدينه دنياس هي ربما الاقصى
خلال اليومين الماضيين موقع الضيافك
القريب جدا من مدينه دونيتك هو الموقع
الرئيسي الذي تستخدمه القوات الاوكرانيه
لاستهداف احياء داخل المدينه خلال ليل
الامس وحتى الان هناك كثافه في الاستهداف
الروسي لموقع افديتك حيث لاحظنا انخفاض
ملحوظ في قدره هذا الموقع على استهداف
احياء هنا في مدينه دنيتك حي كياسكي
واحياء اخرى في المدينه في الجزء الشمالي
من المدينه نتيجه القصف الروسي ايضا هناك
احتدام للمعارك في جنوب ضخمه وهناك اخبار
تتحدث عن ان القتال قرب ضخمه بات من
مسافات قريبه وان المدفعيه نادرا ما
تستخدم وهناك حديث عن اشتباكات المباشره
لكن حتى الان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
والقوات المواليه لروسيا لم تعلن بشكل
رسمي عما يجري في باخمون جنوب باخم تحديدا
وما اذا كانت القوات الروسيه قد احدثت
تقدما نحو ضخمه ام لا ننتظر اعلان الرسميا
في هذا الشان هنا في مدينه دونيتك الليله
الماضيه كانت هادئه بالنسبه للسكان بعد
نحو اسبوع من قصف وصفته السلطات هنا بانه
الاعنف الذي استهدف المدينه منذ شباط
فبراير العام الماضي عفوا بدايه هذا العام
عند بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا او ما تسميها
موسكو العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا هذا
القصف كان قد استهدف بشكل واضح منشات
للمياه ومنشات لتوليد الطاقه في مدينه
دونيتك ما ادى الى فقدان التيار الكهربائي
والمياه في الاف من المنازل داخل المدينه
السلطات تقول انها تحاول استعاده العمل في
محطه تزويد المياه للمدينه ومحطه الطاقه
الكهربائيه لكن الاضرار كبيره جدا حسنا
شكرا لك سلام خضر